Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arhato Sambha Sambhudassam Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arhato Sambha Sambhudassam
Homage to the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
Homage au noble bienheureux, celui qui a atteint l'éveil par lui-même.
Bagawa is a term of address.
Donc Bhagavan c'est un terme avec lequel on s'adresse à quelqu'un.
Comme le Père.
Banti est un diminutif de cela, c'est une petite version de Bhagavan.
Quelqu'un m'a demandé qu'est-ce que Bante veut dire.
Je lui ai dit Adorable.
Arahant signifie que toutes ses défaillances ont été détruites.
Arahant veut dire que tous les obstacles, négativités, ont été aboli.
Donc c'est une personne pure.
Et bien sûr, l'éveil de soi-même signifie qu'il a découvert la voie.
Donc,
Ce que je veux faire ce soir, c'est de voir si c'est clair que nous causons de la souffrance pour nous-mêmes.
C'est clair.
J'aimerais expliquer comment nous causons de la souffrance pour nous-mêmes.
L'importance de cela est que
il est important de voir que c'est nous qui sommes les seuls à pouvoir mettre fin à la souffrance ça a été la découverte du Bouddha il y a une conséquence de cela qui est difficile pour nous de parfois accepter
Donc la conséquence c'est que parfois c'est dur pour nous à accepter cette réalité Et aussi nous ne pouvons pas guérir quelqu'un d'autre de leur souffrance Bien sûr nous pouvons soulager la douleur physique
nous pouvons les réconforter les renseigner par contre en ce qui concerne la souffrance intérieure et bien seule la personne peut la guérir maintenant cette souffrance que nous parlons de point de vue d'un méditateur est résumée dans les 5 hindrances
Donc cette souffrance dont on parle, elle est en quelque sorte résumée dans les cinq obstacles.
Donc c'est important de savoir comment gérer ces obstacles.
Donc la plupart de vous, vous les connaissez déjà, donc c'est plutôt une révision.
Mais pour d'autres personnes, c'est quelque chose qui est nouveau.
Donc il y a plein de choses qui émergent
dans le fait de se complaire dans ce qui est agréable ce qui est important de savoir c'est que le désir, lui, naît dans le cœur
Et donc il se manifeste comme un besoin, un besoin psychologique.
Et donc il recherche quelque chose pour satisfaire ce besoin.
Donc le mot tanha est traduit comme...
c'est aussi traduit comme soif comme un manque si vous pouvez ressentir un désir pour quelque chose
Donc si vous ressentez un désir pour quelque chose qui va en direction d'un objet Et donc quand il va vers cet objet et il essaye de le saisir ou le saisit
il y a un certain sentiment de complétude, de satisfaction mais si vous reculez un peu et puis vous tenez là où il y a la naissance de ce désir donc vraiment la naissance de cela
C'est comme une énorme bouche ouverte.
Il n'y a rien dedans.
C'est le sens d'un vide, mais dans le mauvais sens du terme.
Et, malheureusement, ou au moins c'est vrai pour moi,
si je peux rester avec le désir là c'est très facile pour moi de le laisser passer mais au moment où le désir est déjà en mouvement vers le biscuit il gagne une énergie
Donc il rassemble de l'énergie.
Et donc si nous ne sommes pas attentifs à cette énergie qui grandit, et bien cette énergie va attaquer l'esprit.
Et donc...
Les pensées vont vraiment apparaître autour de boîtes de biscuits.
Soutenu ou soudain ?
Soudain.
Donc ce mouvement, cet espace entre ce désir naissant et puis ce mouvement de saisie est vraiment... Non, le moment d'identité, je veux.
Donc le mouvement d'identité, donc je veux ce biscuit, il est très soudain.
C'est juste comme ça.
Et aussitôt que je veux, j'ai perdu, je suis dans le pouvoir de ce désir.
Donc à partir du moment où je suis dans le je veux, et bien là j'ai perdu, je suis prise, je suis sous l'emprise de ce désir.
Et je saisis le biscuit.
Donc maintenant, dans notre méditation, vous voyez, quand on voit l'esprit s'attraper dans quelque chose qui est vraiment agréable,
Et donc, pendant la méditation, lorsque nous saisissons quelque chose de vraiment plaisant, agréable, donc là, nous sommes déviés de l'esprit.
Nous nous détournons de l'esprit.
Par exemple, nous sommes en train de planifier des vacances.
Et nous nous réveillons et nous notons « planifier, planifier ».
Et vous devez le garder pour une minute, vous voyez, pour vraiment le reconnaître.
Donc il faut vraiment garder ça consciemment pendant une minute, pour un moment.
Et donc, ensuite, il faut se détourner et revenir au corps.
Et là, vous allez prendre conscience de l'excitation.
Donc il faut rester avec l'excitation.
Et donc si vous restez avec l'excitation, peut-être que là vous allez vous rendre compte de cette énergie qui veut retourner dans l'esprit.
Donc vous avez remarqué que je pointe vers la droite, donc ça c'est le cerveau gauche.
Donc vraiment ressentir ce mouvement et attendre qu'il meure.
Et là, nous simplement nous épuisons cette énergie.
Et si nous restons suffisamment longtemps, eh bien, elle va disparaître.
Ça ne veut pas dire que vous ne planifiez plus de vacances.
Parce qu'il y a ce habit dans nous de...
c'est simplement qu'il y a cette habitude de toujours rechercher le bonheur dans le plaisir des sens et si par exemple un de nos grands plaisirs dans la vie c'est de visiter d'autres pays ou d'autres endroits alors
Donc il y a là beaucoup de conditionnement qui va prendre du temps à se dissoudre.
Mais l'important c'est que nous nous enseignons à ne pas être hijackés par ces désirs.
C'est l'important.
Mais ce qui est important, c'est de ne pas être complètement catapulté par ses désirs.
J'ai un ami qui avait l'habitude de faire de longues retraites, de six mois ou plus.
Ça fait déjà il y a un petit moment.
Et entre les temps, il était sexe, drogues et rock'n'roll.
Et sur un seul retour, il a commencé à planifier son voyage vers l'Amérique du Sud.
Et pendant une retraite, il était en train de planifier un voyage en Amérique du Sud.
Et il m'a dit qu'en réalité, ces six mois de retraite, il les a consacrés à planifier ses vacances.
Et ça, ça a été une grande leçon pour lui.
Parce qu'il n'y est jamais allé.
Donc, quand vous apercevez un désir ou quelque chose qui nous attire, et bien simplement revenez au corps.
C'est ce que le Bouddha appelle la renonciation.
La renonciation n'est pas là pour confondre la renonciation avec l'automortification.
Ce qui, dans les scriptures bouddhistes, signifie généralement donner plus de souffrance.
dans le but de dépasser la souffrance j'ai rencontré une fois un homme qui était dans le bouddhisme depuis un certain temps et il avait un mal de dents horrible donc j'ai dit à lui
Je lui ai dit, pourquoi tu ne vas pas chez le dentiste ?
Il a dit, non, je m'entraîne à m'habituer à cette douleur au cas où d'autres douleurs viennent.
Mais comment est-ce que tu sais que la douleur va venir ?
Donc il souffre avec cette douleur de dents simplement parce qu'il pense qu'il aura d'autres douleurs à l'avenir.
Donc la renonciation c'est s'arrêter lorsque nous sommes en train de faire quelque chose pour prendre conscience de nos attachements.
Et donc de rester assis avec cet attachement et d'attendre qu'il passe.
Donc là je suggère un petit exercice pour confronter cet attachement.
C'est pour les personnes qui regardent la télé.
Pour attendre que votre programme préféré vienne.
Attendez que votre programme préféré soit là.
Assurez-vous que vous ayez un verre d'eau à côté.
Assez-vous confortablement.
N'allumez pas la télé.
Observez la douleur.
Et laissez passer, lâchez plus de ça.
Donc il y a quelques années, j'ai regardé une série australienne en trois parties.
Donc c'était au sujet de trois Australiennes qui voyageaient en Europe et qui se rendaient au Maroc.
Et ils ont été trompés en portant des drogues en Espagne.
Et ils ont été trompés.
Et l'épisode s'agissait d'eux être trompés et emprisonnés.
Donc, bien sûr, elles ont été attrapées.
Donc, tout l'épisode était sur le fait qu'elles étaient arrêtées et puis emprisonnées.
J'ai manqué le troisième épisode.
Même aujourd'hui, je me pose la question, qu'est-ce qu'il a bien pu se passer ?
C'est juste une histoire.
Donc, toutes ces, ce que le Bouddha appelle, hindrances,
dans tous ces obstacles sont liés au désir donc plus nous pouvons ressentir le désir et le laisser passer et le plus nous épuisons ce conditionnement ces conditions maintenant malheureusement
Mais heureusement, vous ne faites pas ça seulement pendant la retraite.
Seulement ?
Non, vous ne pouvez pas faire ça seulement pendant la retraite.
Vous le faites tout le temps.
Et ça, c'est difficile.
Donc nous comprenons maintenant pourquoi quand nous revenons à une retraite nous avons l'impression de faire face aux mêmes histoires.
Parce qu'ici nous essayons vraiment très dur de lâcher prise et puis quand nous revenons dans la vie quotidienne nous faisons comme avant.
Donc
si nous pouvons, juste dans nos vies quotidiennes, juste pousser lentement oui, et vous savez, juste très lentement, nous arrêtons le habit si nous considérons un habit très sérieux, vous savez, comme boire et boire vous voyez, les gens souffrent, mais ils éventuellement, vous savez
Donc, par exemple, les habitudes plus graves comme la cigarette ou bien les boissons, eh bien, progressivement, cela change.
Mais le danger, bien sûr, c'est que le manque, le vide est toujours là.
La graine est toujours là.
Et si une personne est trop confiante, très vite elle peut retomber en amour.
Vous entendez des histoires tragiques des alcooliques.
Donc on entend des histoires tragiques à propos d'alcooliques et puis des personnes qui sont accro à la drogue.
Donc là je pense à quelqu'un qui a vaincu l'alcoolisme vers l'âge de 30 ans.
Et il n'a pas bu jusqu'au jour où il a pris sa retraite à 65 ans.
Et là pour célébrer il a pris un verre.
Et comme selon l'histoire il est mort en 3 ans.
Ce qu'il nous dit, c'est que ce manque est très profond dans nous.
Et ce manque a son fondement dans le soi, dans cette idée du soi.
Donc, rappelez-vous, le soi n'est pas une chose.
Donc, souvenez-vous, le soi n'est pas une chose.
C'est une relation.
C'est comme le mot mariage.
Le mariage n'existe pas.
Mais ce qui existe, c'est une relation continue entre deux personnes.
Donc, le soi n'est pas une chose, c'est une relation que nous avons avec cette vie.
Donc le soi n'est pas une chose, mais c'est la relation que nous avons avec la vie, avec cette vie.
Et la relation est duelle.
Donc là nous avons parlé des choses qui étaient plaisantes, mais...
De l'autre côté, il y a toutes les choses comme l'ennui, ce qui nous met en colère, ce qui nous déprime.
Dans ce cas-là, l'émotion est différente parce que l'état mental est négatif.
Mais c'est la même psychologie.
Donc il y a cette haine ou cette peur qui recherche l'objet.
Cela vient d'un attachement à un objet.
Ou l'attachement à une personne.
Ou un mode de vie.
Ah !
As soon as something threatens it, then it must be destroyed, annihilated.
Et donc dès que cela est menacé, cela risque d'être détruit.
Non, il faut le détruire.
Dès que quelque chose le menace, on veut le détruire.
Merci.
And if this attack is felt to be too much, then of course fear arises.
Et donc si cette menace semble trop grande, la peur apparaît.
Et puis la peur fait que nous partons au courant.
Vous pouvez voir comment ces opposés fonctionnent.
À leur extrémité, il y a le meurtre et le suicide.
danger partout mais au moins dans notre méditation nous pouvons voir ce mouvement nous pouvons voir ce mouvement qui veut se complaire, s'adonner dans quelque chose mais on pourrait commencer à voir
Mais nous allons commencer à voir ces choses qui font surgir la frustration ou la colère.
Et ces choses qui font surgir la peur et l'anxiété.
Plus comme des amis.
Parce qu'ils nous montrent où nous avons créé une barrière.
Parce qu'il nous montre là où nous avons créé des barrières.
Si nous pouvons défaire ces barrières un petit peu, ces choses vont commencer à disparaître.
si nous sommes dans une relation et puis nous la saisissons vraiment comme cela est ma relation donc l'autre peut se sentir emprisonné quand ils se déplacent alors il y a de l'angoisse ou peur de la perte
Et donc, quand l'autre bouge, il peut y avoir soit la peur, la peur de perdre, ou la colère.
Pour essayer de le garder plus.
Mais en réalité, si la personne relâche sa saisie, l'autre va se sentir plus libre.
Et en relâchant sa saisie,
Et donc, en relâchant la saisie, il y a moins de peur pour la perte personnelle.
Si je possède une voiture,
C'est une voiture toute neuve.
Il y a beaucoup de peur que des choses puissent arriver à ma voiture, des accidents.
Mais si c'est juste une vieille voiture, un vieil banger,
Donc là ça vous dérange moins si elle est un petit peu cognée.
Pas trop.
Donc, dans la méditation de la salle, nous essayons de voir ce processus clairement.
Donc, pendant la méditation assise, nous essayons de voir ce processus clairement.
Donc, quand la colère a surgi, nous voyons comme c'est quelque chose ou quelqu'un qui a menacé ce que nous avons.
Et c'est pareil avec la peur.
Et c'est la même chose avec la peur.
Et quand nous la perdons, parce qu'il y avait cette saisie, nous ressentons le désespoir.
Le chagrin.
Donc il y a une connexion ici entre
donc là il y a vraiment une connexion entre l'attachement et le fait de se complaire dans quelque chose et puis le sentiment de perte
Donc, en premier, il y a ce sens du besoin, de l'addiction.
Et donc, dans le pire des cas, ça semble à la personne qu'elle est complètement possédée par ce désir.
Elle se sent incapable de dépasser ce désir, surmonter.
Donc ça, c'est le pire des cas.
Dans la méditation, ici, nous pouvons voir qu'il y a toujours un choix.
Donc il y a toujours un moment où nous voyons l'intention que nous choisissons de renforcer.
Donc, quand nous disons à nous-mêmes, je ne peux pas m'empêcher.
Nous n'acceptons pas notre responsabilité complète.
Donc là, dans ce cas-là, nous n'acceptons pas toutes nos responsabilités.
Nous ne sommes pas responsables de nous-mêmes.
Par exemple, dans une relation, l'un d'entre eux part à une relation avec quelqu'un d'autre.
Ils ont eu du sexe ?
Oui ?
Excusez-moi.
Donc, souvent, ils disent, « Eh bien, vous savez, j'ai été... j'ai été... j'ai été... je n'ai pas eu de choix.
» Ils pensaient qu'il n'y avait pas de choix.
Et souvent, ces personnes vont dire, « Ben, je n'ai pas pu faire autrement, je n'avais pas le choix.
» Tu vois ?
Donc... Hein ?
Est-ce que c'est vrai ?
Oui ?
Excusez-moi.
Donc, ce qu'ils font, c'est qu'ils ne prennent pas toute la responsabilité pour leurs actions.
Mais en réalité, ce qui se passe, c'est qu'ils ne prennent pas toute la responsabilité de leurs actions.
Donc, quand nous reconnaissons que nous sommes complètement responsables de ce que nous faisons, vous voyez, c'est en fait une libération.
Mais quand nous prenons conscience qu'en réalité nous sommes complètement responsables de tout ce que nous faisons, alors c'est une libération.
Parce qu'à ce moment-là, nous nous tournons à l'intérieur pour prendre nos responsabilités.
Et cela va nous permettre de nous guérir, de faire l'effort de guérir.
Et avec les plaisir,
Donc avec les plaisirs, il faut être conscient en fait des conséquences Donc quand nous sommes attachés à quelque chose, il y a cette nature compulsionnelle
de l'attachement donc si nous le perdons nous ressentons du chagrin si nous ne pouvons pas l'obtenir nous ressentons de la frustration si nous ne pouvons pas jouer avec nous ressentons de l'ennui
Et nous sommes perpétuellement anxieux de le perdre.
Et quand nous prenons plaisir à quelque chose, nous ne ressentons rien de tout cela.
Mais c'est seulement quand cela s'arrête que là nous réalisons qu'il y a une conséquence.
Donc il faut joindre les deux, de voir la souffrance causée par l'attachement.
Et cela va nous donner de l'énergie à saper nos attachements.
Donc c'est ce que nous faisons ici maintenant.
C'est exactement ce que nous faisons ici, maintenant.
Mais surtout autour du thème d'aventure.
Donc c'est la même technique, le même problème avec tout ce dont nous avons plaisir, tout ce qui nous procure du plaisir.
il y a l'obstacle maintenant de l'agitation donc ça peut être une agitation physique ou une agitation mentale
Donc cela inclut également l'agitation qu'il y a autour de la culpabilité, du remords.
Mais la plupart du temps, nous le ressentons comme étant le corps très agité ou le mental très agité.
Donc quand nous souffrons de cela, si c'est dans l'esprit,
Donc si nous nous apercevons de cela, et bien, si c'est par exemple dans l'esprit, alors notez et puis revenez au corps, notez et revenez au corps.
Et répétez-le constamment.
Donc il peut y avoir des moments où on a vraiment l'impression de devenir fou.
Mais nous devons continuer, ne pas croire à ça, mais juste continuer à revenir.
Et quand c'est dans le corps, ça peut être utile juste de continuer, en commençant du haut de la tête et en faisant notre chemin dans le corps, vous voyez, juste en ressentant toute la restreinté.
et donc si l'agitation est dans le corps c'est bien de commencer par le sommet de la tête et puis de descendre progressivement et de continuer à pratiquer comme ça et donc maintenant si nous parlons du doute il y a un doute qui est bénéfique et qui nous mène vers le questionnement
Donc dans le bouddhisme, si on parle du doute, ça peut être soit le doute dans les enseignements du Bouddha, soit le doute dans la méditation,
ou bien des doutes par rapport à soi, à sa pratique, ou bien dans l'enseignant.
Donc si ce doute nous pousse à investiguer davantage, alors ça c'est un doute qui est bénéfique.
On peut l'appeler aussi curiosité.
Mais si le doute nous arrête de faire quelque chose,
par contre, si c'est un doute qui nous arrête, qui nous empêche de faire quelque chose, alors à ce moment-là, ce n'est pas bénéfique.
Et quand le doute est là, essayez vraiment d'aller à l'intérieur, de le ressentir, et de voir ce qui renforce ce doute.
Je pense que vous trouverez généralement peur.
et en général vous allez trouver la peur quelquefois l'aversion parce que ce doute là sceptique peut vraiment ruiner la vie des gens donc est-ce que je devrais accepter ce travail est-ce que je suis assez à la hauteur je ne sais pas peut-être et puis ils perdent le travail le travail est perdu
Et puis ensuite, l'opportunité du travail est loin.
Est-ce que je devrais être avec cette personne ?
Est-ce que c'est la bonne personne ?
Et puis on attend trop longtemps et puis elle est loin.
Voilà.
So, be careful of skeptical doubt.
Always stay with that feeling if it's there, the fear, you see.
But continue, you know, continue to put faith in the practice, faith in yourself.
Donc, faites attention quand il y a ce doute sceptique de vraiment renforcer la foi dans la pratique.
It can be helpful not to think of life as success and failure, you see.
Et donc ça peut être une aide de ne pas voir la vie comme soit c'est un succès, soit c'est un échec.
Mais plus comme un défi ou bien une erreur.
Un essai, trial.
Trial and error.
On essaie et puis on verra.
Pas l'erreur, on verra.
On n'apprendra pas l'erreur.
donc si vous faites pratiquer comme cela il n'y aura pas de sentiment d'être embarrassé et d'infériorité j'ai créé un centre de méditation au nord de Londres
Donc j'ai établi un centre au nord de Londres.
Donc j'avais cette attitude, essayons.
Donc j'ai dit à la personne qui était avec moi,
que si nous n'avions pas un groupe à la fin du mois de septembre, eh bien, ça ne se produira pas.
Nous avons fait de la publicité partout dans le district.
Dans le district, il y avait essentiellement des grecs orthodoxes et puis des musulmans.
Et l'advertisement avait le numéro de téléphone mauvais.
et puis l'affiche avait un mauvais numéro de téléphone et donc la nuit suivante le voisin est arrivé et nous ne l'avons jamais revu et le lundi suivant personne n'est arrivé
Et donc, arrivé à Noël, c'est devenu assez clair qu'il fallait qu'on sorte de cette histoire et qu'on abandonne le projet.
Donc j'ai été surpris quand je suis allée à la société bouddhiste à Londres.
Il y avait un groupe de personnes comme ici qui se rencontraient tous les jeudis.
Donc je leur ai dit que le centre n'allait pas et que nous allions le fermer.
Et donc, l'émotion principale qui émanait d'eux, ce n'était pas le chagrin.
Vous étiez embarrassé pour moi.
Mais moi, je ne le ressentais pas du tout.
Pour moi, c'était juste, on a essayé, et puis, enfin, c'est erreur.
Donc pour moi, ça veut dire que si vous avez la bonne attitude, vous pouvez tout essayer et puis échouer, c'est OK.
Donc, soyez prudents de la doute sceptique.
Vous savez toujours la doute sceptique parce que ça vous évite de essayer.
Donc soyez vraiment attentifs à propos du doute sceptique parce que c'est celui-là qui va vous empêcher d'essayer de faire quelque chose.
Et puis pour terminer, nous avons ce que mon maître appelle deux très bons amis.
La lethargie et l'endormissement.
They always come and say what you need is a little rest.
Donc ils viennent toujours en disant tout ce dont tu as besoin c'est de te reposer un petit peu.
You need a little power nap.
How do you translate that?
Il faut que tu aies une petite sieste qui va te revigorer.
So, our duty when these feelings come is very simple.
We stay awake.
Donc, notre devoir quand ces sensations, sentiments arrivent, c'est simplement de rester éveillé.
Donc, pour les personnes qui n'ont pas encore essayé cela, vous serez surpris de découvrir...
Donc si votre tête vous semble comme du porridge et que vous êtes au milieu de cet état-là, il est tout à fait possible de se réveiller de cet état comme si vous vous réveilliez le matin avec le soleil qui rayonne.
Donc la force de la léthargie et de la torpeur est proportionnelle à notre attachement.
Donc pourquoi être attaché à l'oubli ?
donc simplement réfléchissez combien de fois étiez-vous allongé dans le lit le dimanche matin ou n'importe quel matin dans cet état d'oubli tranquille confortable, en l'air
Juste en dessous de la conscience.
Donc vous sortez quelques fois de cette étape juste pour vous prouver que vous êtes encore en vie.
Parce que c'est un état vraiment très agréable.
C'est ça la première chose.
La deuxième chose, c'est que nous utilisons le sommeil pour s'éloigner de nos sentiments d'être un peu déprimé, un peu laissé-la-faire, un peu discouragé.
Donc, nous nous mettons sur la couche et nous sommeillons pendant un petit temps.
Nous nous allongeons sur le canapé et puis nous nous endormons.
Donc de manière malhabile, nous avons créé cette énergie qui nous zappe dans ce trou noir.
Et c'est quelque chose dont nous devons vraiment reconnaître, c'est une énergie.
Et donc c'est cela, il faut vraiment reconnaître que c'est une énergie.
Donc c'est vraiment un aimant très fort qui vous attire vers l'oubli.
Et là, notre travail, c'est simplement de rester éveillé.
Et une façon est de garder l'attention en mouvement.
Gardez l'attention en mouvement.
Et une manière de faire cela, c'est de garder l'attention toujours en mouvement.
Donc si vous ressentez cela dans la tête, alors bougez, essayez de voir où les limites se situent, continuez de bouger.
Et c'est pareil avec le corps, vous voyez, où vous ressentez la fatigue ?
Vous le ressentez dans vos gros doigts ?
Donc c'est la même chose avec le corps.
Où est-ce que vous ressentez la fatigue ?
Est-ce que c'est dans le gros orteil ?
J'ai ressenti de la fatigue dans mon gros orteil.
Et simplement de garder l'attention bougée dans le corps vous garde éveillé.
Et en faisant cela, cette attention,
Mindfulness gathers energy towards itself.
Et donc, en pratiquant de cette manière, la pleine conscience va se renforcer et collecter de l'énergie.
Et puis, tout à coup, vous êtes parfaitement éveillé.
Mais si ça devient trop fort, vous pouvez ouvrir vos yeux, vous pouvez vous lever, ou vous allez juste faire une marche.
Mais si l'endormissement est trop fort, à ce moment-là, vous pouvez toujours vous lever ou bien aller faire une promenade.
Mais la chose importante, c'est que si vous allez vous promener, n'allez pas vous promener pour vous débarrasser de cet état de torpeur, mais vraiment pour le ressentir.
Donc vous le passez d'une manière gentille et vous le ressentez toujours dans le corps ?
Et de cette façon, cette énergie s'exhauste, comme n'importe quelle autre énergie.
Et ensuite, vous devez prendre une décision mondiale.
Et là, vous devez faire une décision qui va faire trembler la terre.
Ne plus jamais s'allonger au lit.
Avec l'intention de s'adonner au sommeil.
Donc, ça nous ramène encore à notre gros problème, hein?
Donc là, ça nous ramène à notre problème principal.
Donc, de ne pas avoir d'attente excessive pendant les retraites, à moins que nous mettions de l'effort dans notre vie quotidienne.
Donc si vous utilisez ce papier juste pour glisser à travers et si vous avez des questions, vous pouvez toujours venir me les poser.
Est-ce que vous pourriez en dire plus ?
Vous avez dit que le « self » était une relation.
Est-ce que vous pouvez dire plus sur le soi ?
Vous dites que le soi est une relation.
Est-ce que je peux parler de ça demain soir ?
Il y a des livres écrits à ce sujet.
J'espère que mes paroles ont été une aide.
Je prie que vous soyez délivrés de toute souffrance, tôt plutôt que tard.